Hunter while working on Walter what was
the worst moment and what was that one
time when you pretty much thought you
were going to be just done pull the plug
on it so with Walter I knew that I'd
ultimately finish the film in some
capacity but I think too for me the
hardest part of the filmmaking process
now is getting to that point where
you're letting it go and getting it out
there and not because I have to let it
go and that's really difficult because I
don't know what people are going to
think and this and that that's a little
bit you know you push people going to
judge you but like I'm dealing with the
same old old industry out there and i
still give it so much power like all of
these people that try to shape things
and try to say this is the way you
should do it and you have to you have to
do these windows and all this crap is
garbage it's like you know in this day
and age we can do whatever we want and
we should be doing that and and the
times that I do that I do very well but
with Walter you know I'm like okay I'm
gonna go through the traditional
traditional film festival channel again
and try to get this into Sundance for
the umpteenth time and it's like and
then you know and this time I'm going to
spend you know spend a little extra time
and energy and try to get in touch with
a few of it the key stake like the key
programmers they're the people that
might that might care you know and and
you go through that and you realize well
it's not that they don't care about us
you know they just have they have
there's so much out there and there's so
much money and there's so many places
all around the world that are trying to
produce content trying to buy for that
attention that you start to realize just
how crowded this market is and how how
difficult that is but that gets me
frustrated because I feel like I've paid
my dues you know and I think so many of
us get there it's like God you know pay
our dues we've done this why can't I
catch a break so for Walter the hardest
moment for me it was like when we got
our rough cut done and we started
thinking wow this is a really cool film
that everybody should care about even
though we did it in a low-grade way it's
just it's so important we're all humans
were all going to grow old and die very
soon before we know it and it goes fast
and we're all you know you get a chance
to talk to these people from way back
when that we're born in the 1800s
and it's like it's just something was so
special to me but that's how we all feel
we get so we get so invested personally
in our own thing so so when you start to
go out and you you go hey Sundance hey
South by what do you think of this film
and then they just deject you you know
it's like hmm it's it's a it's a tough
it's a tough moment to have happen over
and over again but best part is and I've
done it every time I turn right around
and I go out there and i make i make my
things count and i continue to have a
career and i have people reaching out to
me that love my work now enough that
they you know potentially want to bring
me in as a creator honest on a
television series or as a you know as
somebody who's going to help lead
another documentary or that they're
going to you know put some of their
company's money into a project that i do
because it gets out there and more
importantly is like you look at netflix
and there's 45,000 ratings on a film you
know or or more and you go god like all
these people are watching this and like
taking the time to put these you know
put these stars and you know give you
give you feedback and sometimes write
you like notes and say hey this is
awesome keep at it so what i realize is
that's who matters that's what that's
what it's all about it has we should not
we should not be so focused on this
old-school industry that's built up
that's making so many people frustrated
you know so that's pretty much it keep
after it
you